Gear for Steve Bay and Francis and Ghana
was so scary when the light is a John
Jones. Ooh, I don't know man.
I don't think they've reached
any sort of conclusion.
I don't know if, um, they
have some sort of an excuse.
I don't know when the trial is.
I think it's a,
it's got to be some time coming up soon,
but it hasn't been in the news.
See if you can find out when the trial is.
It's going to be interesting to see what,
what they say or what
they think it could be
that tell you the craziest rumor about it.
Talked about it on the podcast before.
The craziest rumor was everybody
knows John Likes to party.
I'm not throwing them under the bus. I
mean, he's even joked around, he said, uh,
to DC when DC was talking shit. He's
like, I beat you after I did cocaine.
Yeah. I mean, which is fucking hilarious.
But the craziest rumor was that
they cut Korea teen with cocaine.
It's one of the things they cut cocaine
with and that they use some cheap
Chinese creatine that was steroid tainted,
which is apparently very common.
Apparently there's a lot of uh, Korea
teens and different things that you take.
They have trace amounts of steroids.
It'll show up in a test because the
same vats that they make that shit in,
they make steroids in and
they make everything again.
Then making them in China,
these really shitty bulk places and you'll
occasionally get tainted supplements
happens all the time. Maybe they were
purposely tainted. That could happen too.
We talked about that. The
greatest creotine ever. Yeah.
This should yokes me out.
Yeah, right. Yeah. Probably. Maybe
that's just the way to sell steroids.
You just sell creating.
But what's interesting,
it says California State
Athletic Commission, right?
Because it was in California.
So who gets to decide?
California gets to decide,
is that how it works? Cause it's the
California State Athletic Commission.
So they apparently get to decide
what happens in his future.
Oh, you Sada, you saw if
found guilty this time,
he faces up to a four year ban.
Holy Shit. What's the minimum now?
I don't know.
I mean it really depends on whether
or not he's got an actual excuse.
If he could get that fucking deal or
to get them some coke and it's got the
steroids in that,
I bet you'd never, the problem is
you would only have a decent excuse.
You wouldn't, you wouldn't have,
you wouldn't be exonerated.
There would still be some sort of
a penalty. Wait a minute. Match.
Did you say they're cutting in China?
That cutting creatine with coke or what?
Steroids.
They're using creatine to cut cocaine.
So if you buy cocaine,
see if you've got a kilo of cocaine.
You want stretch that shit
out, man. Kalona quarter. Oh,
I got the thing brow super fucking muscle.
Dick creatine and Super Muscle Dick
Create team has some steroids in it and so
when they're cutting this cocaine with
this Korean team that has steroids in it,
he's snorting the coat. This is he
not meaning John Jones a person.
I'm making this up, right? This is, I
don't know what not your cap. No, no.
This is the room.
Could be.
The rumor is that this has been to task
positive that he did at coke and it had
creating in it and the creative
team had steroids in it.
The rumor is that is what people think
could be a possibility because if John
Likes to party and we
know John Likes to party,
it is entirely possible that he might
have partied and that he might've just had
a little bit of that and in that was this
creating cause like if you think about
it, they're cutting with all kinds of
different stuff. Right. They cut it with,
I mean I'm not a cocaine doctor,
but I gotta imagine they take some white
shit that looks like coke and he can
make more coke. Right. That's
what the cutting is. Right.
But to cut it with Korea team,
apparently it's comic. We looked it up.
We actually do with it. Yeah. Damn.
I thought you were saying that he
was taking Korea team and it had,
it was tainted with steroids.
No,
because that would be better
for him if that was the case.
That would be good because that way you
could take that creatine to Usada and
you'd have to have it on a list of
shit you were taken. He said, look,
it's just says it's Korean team. It's
all I took and they tested. They're like,
oh shit,
this does have steroids in it.
And then they'll go and find another one
that's like from the same that they can
find like the VAT numbers.
I guess they'll find one independently,
hopefully from a store if they test that.
And if they find a trace
amount of steroids and that.
And that's what God, um,
a dirty bird to means. He got off
of that. That's how he got off.
He didn't take any steroids,
just took some fucking over the counter
normal supplement that wasn't supposed
to have steroids in it. And then, um,
he tested positive. He was stunned.
And you've looked at Tim, he
doesn't live, he even lifts weights.
He doesn't even remotely look like a guy
he used to steroids and they tested the
stuff that they found just randomly
in the store and that tested positive.
So he only got a short
amount of a suspension. Hmm.
Yeah, it was pretty quick.
Like six months or something like that.
But even then,
if you didn't do anything wrong,
why would you get six months?
And so you're saying that the steroids
are in Korea team on accident,
not like they're not doing it on purpose,
right? No. Well, here's the thing.
This is just speculation, right? All
I'm here, I'm hearing a rumor, right?
But the speculation is that these
labs where they make creatine,
they also make a gang of other things,
right?
They'll cook up some steroids for ya or
whatever the fuck the order is, right?
And they're not cleaning those vats out,
right?
So if they're just pouring another bag
and they pour out the steroids and they
pour back creatine in there for the next
batch and they're mixing everything up,
it's entirely possible to trace amounts
of those steroids are getting into that
stuff. When we first started
doing alpha brain, we had um,
some of the early versions tested and
when we got the stuff mixed from a place,
the place didn't do a very good job of
cleaning out their equipment and we had
vitamins in our alpha brain,
the weren't in there.
We had some stuff that's
not supposed to be in there.
So when we tested and we
found trace amounts, we had
a switch. What we're doing,
we had to change how we,
how we have the things manufactured.
That's a super common thing when you're
dealing with these overseas laboratories
that are making tea all your shit
together. So that's one possibility.
Another possibility that I've said before,
the lot of people say I'm fucking crazy.
Somebody could have given him something,
somebody could have given him
something to fuck with them.
Somebody could have not liked him.
So we could have done that too.
I'm not saying that's what happened,
but I'm saying you have to take into
consideration all the possibilities.
If John is telling the truth and
he's totally stunned by this,
there's a lot of different possibilities
and one of them could easily be
somebody giving it to them.
It also could be that he took steroids.
That's possible too. I don't know.
If you owned a creating company,
you'd kind of want,
you're creating to be you.
You guys are making steroids there too.
Right? Okay, cool. Can we use the same?
That sucks. That shit. And then you could
always just say, hey, you know what?
I didn't, I don't know what it's
true. Yeah. You know they Perth,
those Dick Pills,
apparently those gas station Dick Pills,
they have like a generic Viagra on him.
That's why they work so well. I know that.
He's just used to say, that's your honor,
your honor. We, they, we didn't know that.
They use the same vats.
Yeah,
they do that and they also put steroids
in those things to do. You know,
Brian Red Band was the first one to call
that Jon Jones had take a dick pills.
That's why I tested positive ray ban.
Put it together in his head because he
does coke. He's like, look, you do cookie.
Dick doesn't work.
Do Your Dick doesn't work.
You take those gas station Dick Pills.
He probably took one of those pills.
He goes, I take those pills. I feel
like a fucking animal. He's like,
I feel like I've got steroids in
me. I'm like, really? He goes, yeah,
you get real aggressive. Dick is hard as
a fucking piece of metal. I'm like, okay,
all right. Turned out he was
right. Hmm. That's crazy.
And it was the same thing
with Anderson Silva.
When Anderson Silva tested positive,
it was from some sort of
Chinese dick pill stuff. Hmm.
And they found it and they tested it
red. That does go hook. He's done it.
He doesn't do it all the time,
but he's done it.
So he knows what it's like to party. And
that's what he was saying. He's like,
I know what it's like if you're partying
and he's like, your Dick doesn't work.
He's like, he parties, right?
Well he probably did cause he
tested positive for coke. He's like,
you probably does that red band totally
nailed it. Or maybe he was doing ecstasy.
People take my Agora on ecstasy, you
know? Yeah. It could be that too. Yeah.
Looked he, he's a wild motherfucker
and he likes to party. The question is,
did he actually take a steroid
with the intention to cheat?
That's what we don't know.
He says he didn't.
I wished there was a weight
that you a hundred Blake,
100% could tell someone's
lying 100% your watch,
that Black Mirror episode
where everything's been
videotaped with her contact
lenses. Yes. So they just like
reviewing everything they've said. Yeah.
That freaked me out.
That's coming.